Speaker 1: Let's get to the most important
bag, which is the mailbag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com
on Fridays.
We will feature some, but not nearly all.
I mean, listen, we get thousands of messages
a week.
We will feature some of the messages that
come in.
Info at David Pakman dot com compliments.
Welcome.
Of course, questions prioritized, criticisms
received, and then trolling more or less ignored.
But not always.
Let's start with the first message.
This one is from Ben and it is about George
Soros.
Ben says, Hello, David.
Is it true that you are being funded by George
Soros?
I have heard that in South Korea, my country,
George Soros and an international Jewish cabal
are trying to destroy the country by funding
mass immigration and low birthrates in order
to achieve world domination.
Is this true?
You know it's not true.
And there's a couple of things going on here.
First of all, George Soros is 92 years old.
I think that at this point, even if at one
point he had his heart set on global domination,
domination through low birth rates and all
these different things that take decades,
if not longer to do.
I think at this point, he's probably done
with that plan.
He is now 92 years old.
And most importantly, no, I am not funded
by George Soros.
Not funded by George Soros, not funded by
the DNC, not funded by whoever you think were
funded by and funded by people in the audience.
Probably not like Ben, but people in the audience
who value what we do and choose to support
it.
Paul wrote in and says, Your stated opinion
in past episodes on YouTube was that you were
doubtful Trump would ever be prosecuted for
the crimes he's committed in light of recent
events at various court proceedings and particularly
the stealing of classified information.
Have you now revised your opinion?
Thank you.
I have.
And as I've said before, I would love to be
wrong on this.
I now believe that Donald Trump is likely
to be indicted and not likely to serve even
a single day behind bars.
That's my current opinion.
And as many of you might know, if you watch
the show at all regularly, I revise my opinions
as information becomes available.
And I think that that's a great thing to do.
It's something that should be encouraged.
And I now believe Trump will be indicted.
No prison time.
Curious to hear from you, your thoughts.
Paul wrote in about student loan forgiveness.
Paul says, David, I know many see the student
loan relief as a good thing, but I see problems
with it.
I will say that I'm happy that it seems well
targeted.
Only $10,000 to people earning under 125,000.
My issue with it is that it's a Band-Aid and
it sets a precedent.
It may help people with debt now, but it won't
convince next year's students to think twice
before taking out large loans that they can't
afford.
And we'll be right back.
In the same place, people will be clamoring
for another round of student loan relief in
five years.
Younger siblings will say, my older sister
got relief.
Now it's my turn.
This can't become an ongoing expectation.
Wouldn't this money be better spent trying
to make education more affordable for future
and current students, rather than forgiving
loans for people who already agreed to pay
them off for giving the interest?
So the debt doesn't keep growing.
But keeping the principle is also a great
idea that I've heard others mention.
Curious to hear your thoughts.
Good show.
Yeah, I've addressed this.
The student loan debt relief won't do anything
to put downward pressure on the price of college
and university and higher education.
And we need to do that.
The system is broken.
I was calculating the other day.
If prices continue increasing.
Over the next eight years.
By the time my daughter would go to college,
the college that my girlfriend went to would
cost $206,000 a year.
All right.
So you're talking like 850 K for four years.
Is that possible or does that sound like something's
broken?
So absolutely something needs to change.
And just a little a sprinkling of student
loan debt relief isn't going to do it.
And so this is two different problems.
It's one problem.
The system is broken.
But there's two different parts to it.
Existing debt and doing something about the
cost of college.
What Joe Biden does does something about existing
debt.
It doesn't deal with the cost of college.
We need, at minimum, free community college.
If tons of people who would go to a four year
school and take on four years of debt say,
hey, you know what?
I'll do my first two years for free at community
college if that happens.
Demand for the four year schools will go down
and those schools will have to, if they want
to increase the number of people who are interested
and willing to go.
They're going to have to decrease prices.
That is one idea.
And there's many others.
Another idea which is controversial to some
is make it more difficult to get the loans.
If it's more difficult to just get a loan
for 400 K to go wherever you want for whatever
degree, if it becomes more difficult, that
would put downward pressure.
So I'm with you 100%, Paul.
This doesn't deal with the second issue.
It only deals with the debt and we need to
be dealing with both.
Clint wrote in about Hillary Clinton.
I don't know what the hell Clint's talking
about here.
Maybe you can help me figure it out.
Clint writes, David, I follow you and listen
to you regularly.
I have to tell you, Hillary's not running
in 2024.
I never said she was.
I worked for her campaign in 2008 and 2016.
The majority of her staff, myself included,
are positioning ourselves for Pete Buttigieg.
You can correct me if I'm wrong.
If you're going to say anything about Hillary,
at least speak positive.
Well, listen, Clint, I will sometimes say
positive things about Hillary and sometimes
I will say negative things about Hillary.
I will say whatever I want about Hillary on
the show.
But in terms of she's not running and speak
poorly, I don't know what you're talking about,
Clinton.
I never said Hillary was running.
I did do a story a couple of months ago indicating
that there are high level Democratic Party
people talking about Hillary running again.
I didn't say it was former, you know, lower
level staff or anything like that.
But Clinton, maybe the message was meant for
someone else.
I don't know.
But we'll see if we can figure out about it.
Chris wrote in and asked, Is losing better?
David, do you think it may be becoming a Republican
strategy to lose just enough elections to
not have a majority power in the Senate, but
still have enough seats to filibuster major
legislation?
And this could apply to the White House in
2024 as well.
My point is they seem to enjoy being able
to criticize everything Democrats do, and
they don't really have any policies to speak
of.
Mitch McConnell always talks about his main
objective is to win elections, but maybe not.
What do you think?
Well, I've addressed this in a very specific
way, which is Republicans in 2024 want to
make the case that Biden should be replaced
with a Republican because he didn't get anything
done.
And so Republicans want to ensure that Biden
and Democrats don't get anything done.
And a great way to do that is to have divided
Congress, Democrats controlling the Senate
and Republicans controlling the House.
It's a great way for in the lead up to the
24 election, Republicans to be able to say,
look, they've had the White House for four
years.
They've had the Senate for four years.
And when's the last time they got anything
done?
And of course, there would be that two year
stretch where nothing gets done because Republicans
control the House.
So I don't know about the bigger picture,
Chris, of just never get anything done.
But I think in the immediate, that's exactly
their goal with Joe Biden and Democrats over
the next two years.
Terry wrote in and said, You messaged me and
I'm going to keep doing this for as long as
I have to.
Terry said, David, I was watching your YouTube
show last night and I got two messages that
appeared to be from you.
It was WhatsApp and it said, Right, me, I
don't use WhatsApp.
I've never twitted and I certainly have never
Instagram crack or anything.
Keep on rocking, brother.
Yeah.
So listen, I am not trying to DM or WhatsApp
anybody in the audience.
There are rampant scammers on our YouTube
channel and they will put my face.
Imagine that this face, they put my face as
their profile image and they respond to people
in the comment and they say, Hey, I'd love
to chat with you directly.
Please WhatsApp me DM me here, this, that,
the other thing.
And it's a scam.
They want to steal your money.
Okay, we report them to YouTube as fast as
we can.
You can report them to YouTube, say that they
are impersonating me and YouTube will ban
them, but it's like whack a mole.
Okay, so I'm not trying to contact anyone.
The only time I'm in touch with viewers is
when they call in.
When we take calls.
All right.
So not me.
Don't fall for it.
Jeffrey asks, Should we leave the country?
This is sad situation.
Jeffrey says, I've been concerned for a while
now that if an autocrat is elected in 24,
it may be time to really consider leaving
the U.S. and moving to a country that has
a stable democracy.
Through my work, I could get a visa in a Scandinavian
country, Andorra.
My wife has dual citizenship in Australia.
I think it's important for my children to
live in a safe, free country and I'm concerned
we could be seeing the end of such a country
here in the US.
Leaving the country has always seemed like
a drastic step to me, but it seems it's becoming
more of a reality.
What do you think?
Well, you know, every time this comes up,
people get mad at me and they say, David,
you're dripping with privilege when you talk
about this.
It is a reality that I was born in Argentina,
so if I needed to go to another country, I
could go back to Argentina.
And by the way, if you look at the economic
situation and who's in power right now down
there, it's it's no it's no dream to be down
there.
Okay.
But it's something.
All right.
As an individual of the Jewish persuasion,
as who was it that said?
I don't remember.
Anyway, I'm Jewish.
I could go through a process.
I believe it takes a year or two to get citizenship
in Israel.
And yes, because my family is originally from
Western Europe and fled right before the Holocaust,
Poland has a program where I could request
citizenship because my grandfather was from
Poland.
I'm working on it.
I still don't have the documents.
I need to do that.
So, yeah, I'm.
I'm working on a backup plan for sure.
Now, am I in this like I'm moving to Canada?
DeSantis wins in 24.
Now, first of all, it's really hard to move
to Canada.
I don't know how many of you have looked into
it, but no, I'm not saying that.
But what I would say, Geoffrey, is.
You are going to do what is best for your
family.
And so I would have the plan in place.
Why not give yourself options?
And then if the time should come, you can
avail yourself of those options.
What else can I say?
Noah wrote in.
And said, David, do you think Donald Trump
will be indicted and sentenced for the rest
of his life?
No, I don't.
I do believe at this point, increasingly that
it is likely Trump will be indicted.
I don't think Trump's going to do a single
day behind bars.
Opening that one up to the rest of you.
If you believe Trump is going to do prison
time any at all, write in info at David Pakman
dot com.
Leave a youtube comment, send a tweet, leave
a Facebook message, respond to me on troth
central whatever.
I don't believe he will do a single day.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
You can sign up for the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Packman dot com.
Speaker 4: Oh the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
All right.
Join Pacman dot com.
You can use the coupon code, big e-voting
22 to get a discount.
And I will either see you on the bonus show
or once we return from the Labor Day long
weekend.